the City Council of Louisville Kentucky
is outlawing no-knock warrants nearly
three months after police there shot and
killed Brianna Taylor a no-knock warrant
allowed three plainclothes officers to
burst into her apartment while she was
sleeping national correspondent Jericka
Duncan spoke with Taylor's mother about
the new law and Jericka there's also
similar legislation in Congress correct
that's right
Anthony Rand Paul introduced that
legislation it's called the justice for
Brianna Taylor Act which would end these
warrants nationwide Taylor's mother who
told me her daughter would have been 27
years old last week said her daughter
was a loving person whose death could
have easily been prevented with a
unanimous vote late Thursday the
Louisville Metro Council passed
Brianna's law officially banning
no-knock warrants countywide attorney
Ben Crump and the law is only the first
step and getting justice but these
officers need to be terminated and
charged for this unnecessary and
justifiable killing of tameka's first
boy just after midnight on march 13th
police used a battering ram to enter
Taylor's apartment believing it was
being used by a drug dealer to receive
packages while the plain clothed
officers contend they identified
themselves Taylor's boyfriend says they
did not and he opened fire to defend
himself against what he thought were
intruders he later called 911 at least
eight times Taylor tonight autopsy
no she's a newly-released
incident report by Louisville Police is
mostly blank saying there was no forced
entry and marks Taylor's injuries as
none attorney lenita Baker not a single
officer has been charged and worse not a
single officer has been fired
Miss Palmer how are you coping with
everything are you exhausted I'm
definitely exhausted I hate what
happened she deserves justice do you
think she'll get justice I pray she does
but for now the family is grateful that
Taylor who was an emergency medical
technician is being honored by
Louisville slaw makers she's a blast
what she was here on earth and she
should continue to save lives with
Brianna's law they heard named Brianna
Taylor in the past police have said they
used these no-knock warrants to keep
suspects from fleeing the scene
destroying evidence or even firing at
police officers the mayor of Louisville
confirms he will sign this bill into law
as for that incident report that mostly
blank incident report police acknowledge
those errors and now say they're working
to correct them glad some remarkable
developments there in Louisville jerrika
thank you very much